hello
i'm brian and we're here to talk about
where should i run my stuff
so like all good questions in technology
the answer is it depends and
that's the reason there's this whole
talk so we're gonna talk through what it
depends on and
how to how to make these decisions right
and basically i'm going to go through
each of these
except firebase and talk about
kind of what they are what their sweet
spots are and
you know what the trade-offs are like
how you might make a decision between
them
um and then some more kind of bonus
stuff around
um how they can work together so
each of these i think of have as part of
kind of a
abstraction layer kick so the top things
are more abstract and at the bottom
they're more concrete so the bottom we
have vms
right at the top firebase is
a tool for people writing mobile apps
and web apps where they don't want to
think about the back end at all
so it's kind of all handled for you down
one level
is cloud functions and it's like a
really good fit for things that are
primarily event driven
or perhaps kind of glue next down
we have app engine and if we're thinking
about kind of an entire web app
all together next one down
combines web apps and events with
containers so you can run
anything that runs in a container and
serve it up on the web
with no fuss level down is kubernetes
engine which is hosted kubernetes
for running whole clusters of machines
running an application or multiple
applications with lots of containers
and then next level below that is
straight vms virtual machines
run anything you want to that runs on a
computer
and by the end of this i'm gonna
basically try to convince you that
like this is a comparatively low risk
decision
uh don't worry too much about like the
right or wrong uh choices here
but we'll still give you good info on
where to start so
let's go through this and we'll start
kind of top to bottom
and start with cloud functions so cloud
functions
are a function running the cloud i guess
name makes sense
and you know it's basically you write
the function that takes some
parameters in uh perhaps has some side
effects
and returns a value and we handle all
the rest
um and you write that in one of a few
programming languages
and these functions are triggered
by an event happening somewhere else in
the system either
coming in from the web or from our
message queue pub sub or from cloud
storage which is our object store um
so something happens in the world and
then your function gets called
that's the high level model there and
all the rest of the infrastructure is
managed for you
you pay for what you use and it auto
scales up and down
so as the as a developer you're thinking
about what events
make up your system and what the
definitions
of the functions are so this is a really
good fit
for serverless right it's almost kind of
fits the definition of serverless
um it you know is a really good choice
when you've got
pub sub or cloud storage as a key part
of your application um
any time that you really don't want to
think about the runtime environment at
all just
how the pieces connect it's a good fit
um
[Music]
data transformation people don't
necessarily think of that as a top-level
thing but you've got
information coming in a regular basis
and you need to make it into a slightly
different format
um that sort of thing and my favorite is
i just think about it as kind of web
glue so we've got
all these different apis that help you
do lots of different stuff and
sometimes all you need to make a system
is to connect two or three of them
together
in a particular way and boom you've got
some real value
so it's it's a good fit for that sort of
thing
on the constraint side since like you're
thinking about functions all the time
it's only functions and when you start
having lots of them it can be
a little bit challenging to kind of keep
track of them or debug that sort of
thing
um all of the interaction is via events
so if you want to start them yourself
you have to come up with some other way
to
kind of poke it and it
we support certain specific language
runtimes pretty good variety but
if it matches what you need great if it
doesn't
you may have to look somewhere else okay
next level down is app engine so app
engine
is you know arguably i mean it is the
kind of like earliest um cloud
thing that google did uh as a developer
product
uh before we even had the the name
google cloud
and its goal is to really help
developers
just focus on the code so you've got a
full code base that handles mapping urls
to different parts of the code um
there's a couple different data stores
that you can use with it nicely
and all the rest of the infrastructure
is handled for you so you're thinking
about your whole app
and like all the different parts of the
web uh urls
that have handlers
since it is you know very mature thing
it has deep support for things like
versioning
uh traffic splitting um a lot of
granularity in a you know seeing what's
going on with it
um that sort of thing um i think
you could you could arguably say you
know it was serverless
before it was cool uh before that term
was kind of really
like in popular use um as a developer
when you're using app engine you're
you're really thinking about the code
base
you know all of the code that makes up
your app and the particular
web requests that come in and which
parts of the code you want them to hit
you know what handler and what you want
to do about that um as the
primary things like that's where you
spend almost all your time
and then additionally you know this kind
of idea of okay here's a new version of
the code
i'd like to test that out with a small
amount of the traffic or kind of
move forward or roll back afterwards
it's a really good fit for you know an
application that is
https http or https kind of web driven
app
for things that are kind of primarily
stateless or
you know use one of our managed
databases and
especially for scaling really quickly
from from perhaps very low levels of
traffic to very high levels of traffic
um one of the sweet spot use cases is
things like
uh kind of landing pages for seasonal uh
events or things like that where
it doesn't get really used for most the
year and then suddenly super busy
on the constraint side like you know
again you
we have certain language runtimes that
are kind of fully supported things like
java php
python go node and
it you really are speaking uh web
requests like the request response
that's how you have to talk to app
engine
next level down the abstraction tree is
cloud run
and this is where serverless kind of
really connects with containers
and you know so what's container y
containers um
could go into a lot of depth here but
you know concretely we're talking docker
containers
and i think of them as really solving
the problem you have where like
the software works one way on one on
your dev environment but doesn't work in
production
you're like well worked on my machine
you know or that sort of thing so
basically they wrap up the program all
the files it needs to run
maybe some data files and some stuff
into a zip file that gets pushed to a
repository
and then that gets pulled down and every
single time the program's run it sees
the same initial state
so it kind of solves that problem so
containers are lovely
they let you run kind of almost any
software in them
and cloud run is a way to take anything
that does run in a container
on linux and connect that to the web
connect that to the internet and so
basically
you listen you know for hdb traffic and
cloud run handles the rest of it it does
ssl termination for you
it does the actual traffic routing to
the different
processes so it might run one it might
run 50 to handle the amount of traffic
you have
and in fact um
fairly uncommonly it can actually send
multiple requests to the same process so
if you've got a process written in
java go what have you where it can
handle multiple concurrent requests at
the same time
you can do that in cloud run and since
you're build
on kind of like while that process is
actually running
you can handle multiple requests in the
same process and save money
so that's really nice it scales up and
down very quickly
and very granular billing on usage
so when you're writing something in
cloud run
uh you are thinking about building out
that whole image
uh the software that runs in it which
files are there um
that sort of thing and then also it's
kind of up to you to figure out
how you want to build that image so if
you anything from doing it as a one-off
on your computer or
more likely you're using a build system
of some kind
that then pushes uh the resulting docker
image up to a repository and then when
you
set up cloud run you basically say pull
from this repository and run the
processes from there
and the the contract is pretty simple
you
you look at an environment variable for
what port to listen on
and you start a web server and do work
um and then the other kind of
constraints is that
there's no local persistent storage for
that process so this lets
us scale up and down uh kill processes
start processes different places
and handle lots of traffic for you um
so that contract's not super uh
onerous like it's not a super big deal
so
that means you can run nearly any
software um
that runs in a container and run that in
this very scalable way so it gives you a
lot of flexibility
it's a really good fit for workloads
that are
inherently stateless um for things that
are kind of web
hp request response and in particular
where you have specific dependencies
needs you need to run a certain
programming language um
like if you want to run something
written in cobol or fortran
uh and put it on the web on google cloud
this is going to be a really good place
to start
um or if you've got really particular
module dependencies maybe you've got a
python module that needs a c
library written in c and needs to work a
certain way this is a good place to run
that
on the constraint side you do have to
think about and use containers so it's
up to you to figure out how you want to
do that build
and then in addition to what i just
talked about was the fully managed
portion of cloud run there's also the
same exact
contract can be supported on top of
kubernetes so
you can then anything you write to run
in cloud run
can run anywhere kubernetes runs so that
can be on google cloud or
another cloud or on your own computers
wherever you've got kubernetes going
so that's really powerful which brings
us
to kubernetes and
kubernetes itself is an open source
project uh it's
essentially a de facto software for
running containers at this point
um i think of it as kind of when you're
like hey containers that
runs on my machine thing that's a good
idea let's do a lot of it and you end up
pretty quickly with thousands and tens
of thousands of containers and you
want to figure out how to manage them
that's the the problem space that
kubernetes was built to help you with
um so it helps with that it helps you
insulate yourself from different
physical environments of computers
and then i think it really helps with
the mental model of thinking about an
application instead of
how the computer is talking to each
other and then
kubernetes engine is the google cloud
hosted version of kubernetes
so we handle the machine updates you
know
we make it really easy to get the
cluster set up and get connectivity to
it
um help you scale up and down things
like that
so when you're using kubernetes you were
thinking about the logical
infrastructure
um and i like to think about this as
kind of like the whiteboard so when you
and a colleague get together and you
like start drawing lines and boxes
um on the board to explain how things
work kubernetes actually works
at pretty close to that level so like
things that would be a box and a line
you're gonna make a configuration file
that represents that you know
a yaml file somewhere uh to do that and
so you're really
thinking at that level of abstraction
and it's really powerful
um so you know what are the programs how
they connect
where do they source date uh how do they
find each other what else are they
allowed to do
things like that it's a particularly
good fit
for anytime you have a complex software
setup you know microservices or just
like half a dozen pieces that are trying
to talk to each other
and you need to run that in multiple
environments so if you need to run it in
a test environment a broad environment
and have it work the same way
or in different legal environments where
you have
your main instance of the cluster maybe
runs somewhere and then you need to run
another instance in another country
because they have specific rules around
that
your company needs to follow so you can
write the code
and the uh the management you know
work and do it in the same way in both
those environments
so that's really powerful and you know
it grew up with containers it's
all about helping you run containers so
if if you and your team
is like focused on using containers and
like getting the most out of them
this is probably a really good fit for
that and
related to that though i think it it's
all in on containers so it really means
you
you need good communication between the
different teams and the roles
so you know your dev folks and your
operations folks and your security focus
like all need access to the same
repository
so that when there is a security patch
that comes out
they can patch the the same place that
the development work is happening so
that it gets up to production the same
way
that sort of thing and you know that
kind of gets into the constraints a
little bit so like
you know you need to be using containers
it's up to you to figure out
you know how you're going to coordinate
the uh the builds of those
and how your teams are going to work
together and then you know there can
be occasionally some challenges around
licensing or
um certain architectures but around
licensing in particular because it's a
pool of machines some licenses want to
be machine specific and so
there's some options for doing that but
you have to do a little bit more
configuration
um and then so but all of that is true
of kubernetes like all these things this
insulation
and uh abstraction that sort of thing
the other point i just wanted to make is
that
i think um part of the reason anybody
cares about containers and
kubernetes is a whole a big one that's
not talked about too much is that it
helps you save money
you can run more software on the same
computer or virtual machine
without it like messing up the other
software on the same computer
because the containers insulate them
from each other and that means you can
get higher utilization you get more work
done
for the same amount of money so that's
really valuable
and then kubernetes engine itself you
know gets you all that
um and with more management of the
cluster itself
as one big advantage and the other is
you know sometimes it's not clear
whether kubernetes is going to be a good
fit for
you or you want to learn it or whether
it's going to work on a given project
and a managed cluster is just the
easiest way to get started
you can have a cluster going in five
minutes and then play with kubernetes
even if you don't actually intend to run
it there long term it's gonna be way
easier to get it started and figure out
you know whether it's a good fit for
your problem so i recommend that
next up is compute engine so
these are virtual machines and i'm going
to come back to this phrase but i like
to think about it as
a slice of a data center so
basically it's a computer you know and
you've got a certain amount of memory
and disk and network
and uh cpu the the thing that makes
like our general purpose machines in
particular really awesome is that
you basically have a separate dial as an
option on each of those things
you can attach multiple disks or
different size disks to any of the
size machines you can have machines that
have more memory
or more cpu depending upon the actual
workload you have
so basically you don't have to pay for
the part of the computer you're not
using
and it makes it easier especially for
like beefier
systems to make a machine that just
matches the
the kind of work that that machine is
doing you get the most efficiency and
not anymore i guess not wasting anything
and then we do have a few specialized
machine types that are extra-large
in either memory in particular for
running things like sap hana in memory
databases
or for doing really compute intensive
workloads uh so take a look at those
and then as a whole all of these you
know they start very quickly
and we have a lot of different operating
systems that are
part of compute engine you know that we
kind of do redistributions of that have
a few extra tools in them
to make it really easy to run so that's
debian centos core os
ubuntu red hat suse and
of course you know windows server
different editions so
take a look at those and if you need to
you can also kind of roll your own
distribution
or build a custom organization specific
version of one of these and re-save that
um and i want to talk about just for a
moment because that's where like i think
this we normally think of a vm as a
slice of one computer
and you know our disks and network in
particular are really you're getting a
slice of the whole data center
the default disks the persistent disks
are network attached storage
but they're on really fast networks and
the blocks are spread out across
thousands of machines
um so you get you know most of what you
would get out of a san
for every disk so things like you can
take an image of the disk
while it's running restore that onto
another computer to look at it
you can make any of the disks larger
while the computer is running
you can have disks that are replicated
and actually live
in one region spread across multiple
failure zones
things like that really help out a lot
and can drop whole parts of your
architecture out
um make things easier to run and operate
and then they're more than just
computers so
there's this like handy thing you can do
where if you just want to run one vm
or one container on a vm you can just do
that and we'll handle starting the os up
and
run the container and downloading it and
you just don't worry about it and
that's super handy if you need a really
big container for example
or you just don't want to mess with the
complexity of running a larger
system and then on top of all the vms
there's this
you know api called managed instance
groups and it lets you
treat a whole group of machines as one
so you have a template
for the os disk and there's a dial
basically for how many copies of that
you'd like to run
at any time is you can say okay i want
more or i want less and we'll start up
the vms
handle the load balancing and all that
sort of stuff and
connect them all and have that work um
and then in addition you can
set that up to be automatic so that it
scales based on traffic or you can run
different versions of the app and see
how they're doing
um things like that and then the load
balancer itself
is actually also a data a data center
level construct so
when you change the config of the the
load balancer you're actually
changing the configuration for the whole
data center and the same load balancers
we use for gmail
and for youtube are serving your traffic
and so it's not going through like one
particular box somewhere so it can scale
up really fast
not limit you know the traffic so
when you're using vms you're kind of
thinking about everything right you're
thinking about your software
you're thinking about the operating
system you know the disks you're making
for that
you know the the configuration of the
machine how much cpu ram and disk
um the networking how they talk to each
other firewalls load balancing
kind of all of it um so it's a lot but
at the same time it gives you the
flexibility to run
pretty much anything that already exists
so if you have an existing system
it's probably going to be where it where
it fits um
yeah on that note like it's like lift
and shift like the
a system that's already running like
this is probably where you're going to
want to
start running that that use case i
talked about for like i just want to run
a container
really handy also you know if you have
very particular licensing requirements
you know it's maybe bound to a
particular machine
we can handle that on compute engine or
if you need a particular kernel
or kernel extension or even a very
specific os you know maybe even a custom
os all that can be done on compute
engine
um and you know it is where i think most
people
run kind of intensive databases you know
it's running on top of compute engine
including like our managed cloud sql
instances are in turn running on compute
engine
and you know you can speak you know kind
of any ip protocol
um network service so any tcp
protocol based network service so um
it's a good fit for a really wide
variety of things
on the constraint side most of it is
that you end up having to think about
more
and you have to decide how to handle
software updates and the
uh adding a new computer takes like 20
30 seconds so
there's a larger chunk of time before
you can respond to new traffic
okay so did did i answer this question
of like where where's i wrote my code
um basically we went through this whole
abstraction tree right things are more
abstract on top
and then kind of get more concrete as we
go down
and each of them has a sweet spot so
if in talking about that like you were
like oh hey this is the one for me
great go start there um take a look at
that maybe look at the ones next to it
um but you know got it
let's let's start there do that um
but there's it still depends right and
and i want to talk about a few other
things it might depend on
uh so there's this abstraction level
there's technical requirements of the
software you're building
and then there's your team like what are
the humans you know what do
what do they like doing what are they
good at doing uh how do the different
teams get along
there's some factors there to think
about so let's go into those
so abstraction i think we kind of spent
the most time on this basically
you know what what are the things your
team
likes uh thinking about what is the best
best fit for the problem you're working
on
and that may drive you to pick a
particular one of these
um so think about that additionally
there are technical requirements for the
software
and these generally pull you down the
abstraction
hierarchy so if you for example need to
use a gpu right now um that's gonna
pull you down into kind of the lower
level uh items
um if you need a really specific linux
kernel
that's going to pull you all the way
down to vms so look at what your
technical requirements are make sure
that they work
on um on the servers you want to use and
occasionally it may pull you down a
level
um billing model i didn't talk as much
about
but you know basically the top half is
based on
transactional usage you know this a
request comes in
and it costs a small amount of money to
to serve that request
you get that sort of thing going on at
the bottom we have more of a
while it's on it costs money so you're
making a reservation
and even if you don't use it it still
costs money so it's it's really to your
advantage to use it
all the way get high utilization
so you know how the billing
works for your software and how your
organization thinks about billing
that also may affect the decision
and then also the team you know who if
your
group is entirely made up of developers
who don't want to think about computers
at all
and want to focus on the code they're
writing you're more likely to be higher
up
in the abstraction and if you have a
kind of a
multi-team group that has really
particular opinions about how things
should be configured and how they should
work together
you're much more likely to be kind of
lower in the abstraction hierarchy here
so take a look at your team makeup and
you know
also just what you're good at what you
like doing um that may influence
your decision as well and then also just
you know how long has this code existed
um i think
generally i recommend if you're starting
something new try to start high
up in the abstraction higher key it's
going to save you time
it tends to be relatively easier to move
down
it's to your advantage to start and stay
up as high as you can as long as you can
whereas if you've got existing code it's
almost always going to
work on compute engine and if it's in
containers it's probably going to work
on
uh kubernetes or maybe even cloud run so
you know likely you kind of start
towards the bottom and work your way up
over time so maybe you
migrate into the cloud and then you move
parts of the system into other things
later
things like that so um
think about those things and then when
it comes to like you know did i make the
right decision
um actually realistically most systems
are made up of multiples of these
together um
so it's pretty common for example to
have
a you know it's primarily a kubernetes
based system but you've got a few
existing apps that run on their own vms
and you've got some glue that runs in
cloud functions
for example or you know you might have
any
different set of combinations there so
that happens uh
it's common and normal so you know
just pick the right thing for each part
of your system so that's a good
option there and we have a couple tools
to make that
easier to do and as you get more moving
parts they become more and more useful
so
pub sub is our durable
and high throughput message queuing
system so you can
pass messages around in different parts
of the system without you know them
necessarily being up or you know about
them
and cloud storage is an object store
it's a key value store that lets you
save information so that some other part
of the system or you later can pick it
up again
so for the stateless parts of the system
if you're using lots of serverless
chances are you'll store things longer
term in cloud storage
things like that um or
you may decide to move up or down these
abstraction levels as you learn more
about your applications so you know you
may start up high
and then later be like actually you know
there's already in a container we're
going to move it down a level so that we
can get access to something
a little more specific or you know we
we're adding a piece to the system that
has a new technical constraint and that
might pull you down
or you might be kind of starting down
low and decide you want to get some of
the management
benefits and you know to move you up a
level so we try to make it relatively
easy to move up and down
um it you know once you're in containers
it gets relatively easy to do that
it's almost always just very
straightforward to go kind of down a
level
sometimes it takes a little bit of work
to kind of move up an abstraction level
but
that's definitely an option and then we
try to make the behavior as similar as
possible
between these different environments so
there's a metadata server
that is available you know in each of
these that you can get things like
security tokens from uh you can log
to stackdriver and do monitoring
alerting it's the same way
using the same code whether it's running
in any of these environments so
try to make it pretty easy to get back
and forth
and that brings us back to uh you know
our high level thing here so
you know these i think are again like
the sweet spots you know the
definitely you know things overlap a bit
you know so you
you have a choice between kind of two or
three of these sometimes um
but i think these are like what i'd like
you to remember
you know we've got an app that looks
like it's just a web app you know think
about starting with app engine you know
if you've got an existing system
probably think about starting with
compute engine that sort of thing
and if you'd like to get some more info
here's some links and urls to go read a
bunch more
there's some quick starts for trying
things out and the like and
my twitter handle is brian dorsey and
feel free to email me
at google thank you very very much for
your time
take care